bonjour je vois que ça commence bien
soyez les bienvenus pour ce conseil
national qui est un conseil national
important pour nous tous
il s'agit aujourd'hui de donner à la
france l'image une famille politique
prête à gagner les régionales c'est
notre mobilisation c'est l'essentiel de
notre conseil national et on a besoin de
tous rassemblés pour pouvoir donner à
nos régions les dynamiques nécessaire et
poursuivre ce que nous avons engagé avec
les élections municipales c'est à dire
l'alternance bleus pour délivrer la
france
ce conseil national a donc deux
objectifs des objectifs statutaires
il faut investir nos listes régionales
il faut avoir quelques modifications
dont on vous parlait notamment on va
adopter notre budget notre projet de
budget notre trésorier va vous en
parlait dans quelques instants
et je vous propose tout de suite un
premier vote statutaire puisque vous le
savez c'était un engagement de nicolas
sarkozy pour la présidence de l'ump qui
est devenu les républicains depuis et
nous avons décidé de faire élire les
présidents de fédérations par l'ensemble
des adhérents
il nous faut donc modifier nos statuts
dans cette perspective un carton vous a
été remis
à
je vois je vois kahn a quand même qu'ils
ont ce qu'il faut c'est que tous les
conseillers nationaux l'est ce carton
vous le présenter à la tribune bleus
si vous êtes pour en rouge naturellement
si vous êtes opposés on a choisi quelque
chose que tout le monde comprend assez
facilement
nous sommes contre le rouge et pour le
bleu donc on va vous proposer un vote
sachez que ont fait ça comme ça c'est le
trésorier qui m'a dit ça par rapport au
vote électronique et tous les votes
technologique
ça fait dix-sept mille euros d'économie
donc ça vaut quand même la paix
donc le premier vote que je vous propose
il doit s'afficher normalement ici donc
il s'agit d'une modification simplement
de deux mots dans nos statuts pour d'une
part que la liste des candidats quel
rendu public 30 jours au moins avant la
date du scrutin
il est proposé de faire quinze jours
avant la date du scrutin
pour ces élections puisqu'elles seront
20 janvier le président deuxièmement de
la fédération est élu par l'ensemble des
adhérents de la fédération
naturellement un jour de cotisation au
scrutin direct et à bulletins secrets à
la majorité absolue et il est procédé à
un second tour
il y avait avant le même jour s'il ya un
second tour avec tous les adhérents
c'est pas forcément le même jour et donc
on vous propose de supprimer ce même
jour de manière à ce que ça puisse être
sur deux jours différents
voilà le vote que je vous propose c'est
de l'article donc 8,5 et 10 4 du
règlement intérieur
approuvez-vous ces deux modifications le
scrutin est ouvert qu'est pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient et il me semble
que c'est adopter
je laisse la parole à notre trésorier
daniel fasquelle en le remerciant de
tout son engagement pour cette fonction
dans ton c'est qu'elle est à la fois
difficile et dangereuse et il a donc
tout notre soutien et notre estime et
après nous voterons le budget 2016
après son exposé c'est à toi de